[Music]
the US Court of Appeals for the DC
Circuit has issued an administrative
stay of a lower court's ruling ordering
former White House Counsel Don began to
appear before Congress the court says it
will continue issuing a longer stay and
set oral arguments for a hearing January
third a federal judge ruled Monday Magan
would have to appear before Congress in
response to a subpoena rejecting the
Trump administration's argument that
absolute immunity shielded top aides
from congressional questioning
congressional lawmakers are back home
for the holidays when they return to
Washington next week impeachment of
course will be the big issue let's get
some perspective on that tonight Bret
Baier spoke with West Virginia
Republican senator Shelley Moore Capito
earlier this week senator Shelley Moore
Capito of West Virginia thanks for being
here good evening nice to be on thanks
obviously the focus in Washington has
been and will be likely for the next few
weeks at least impeachment and it seems
like it's heading towards your side of
the Capitol with you as a juror as you
sit here tonight having watched what
you've watched how do you see this well
I see it as the political blunt
instrument that it has been through the
entire process when the hearings were
private it was pretty obvious that the
Democrats were using this as a way to
you know be destructive to the Trump to
President Trump himself and then when it
comes into the public arena over the
last several weeks I think it's shown
itself again to be a very divisive very
partisan exercise and discouraging to
the American public but I will it will
be coming over probably to the Senate I
will be a juror so you know I'm all ears
of course to try to figure that out once
it comes onto my plate well to that
point one of the people making the case
is the House Intelligence Committee
Chair Adam Schiff here is his closing
argument in essence at the end of that
committee hearing when the founders
provided a mechanism in the Constitution
for impeachment they were worried about
what might happen if someone unethical
took the highest office in the land and
used it for their personal gain and in
of you there is nothing more dangerous
than an unethical president who believes
there are above the law said there there
are some Republicans will heard from
Texas others who said that what the
president did and how he did it was
inappropriate but not impeachable well I
think that you in that camp well I think
probably that his his inquiries could
could be construed as such but all the
evidence that we've seen have been
second and third-hand evidence so I'll
take what Adam Schiff in his own words
and the seriousness which which he said
it I think he protests too much in his
his closing statement because he knows
that the facts are not there the
president hasn't been able to defend
himself and so the process has been very
much not what our founders wanted and
not what our rule of law is founded on
but as being used as a divisive partisan
exercise and it's not doing justice to
our system the Washington Examiner this
week had this in an opinion piece saying
Republicans should admit that trumps
demands on Ukraine were improper if they
are reasonably enough unconvinced that
impeachment is the remedy they should
take other actions to steer Trump toward
putting true national interests over
petty personal interests is censure
something that you think the Senate is
going to look at well I think that you
can see that drumbeat beginning to
develop in the House of Representatives
several members or at least one member
has mentioned that already I don't I
think it's going to be predicated really
on what the house brings over to the
Senate and what is laid on the Senate's
played in terms of the articles of
impeachment you know I think that if you
look at the whole transcript of the
phone call within the few minutes or so
that the president you know made a
statement about investigating corruption
and mentioning an opponent yeah maybe
that wasn't the exact proper way but the
corruption issue is still I think a very
viable issue in in Ukraine and and
something that we know that if we just
find countries without where the money
is going to go without looking at
corruption we're gonna get what we
deserve back which was not satisfied
action if you look at this latest Q poll
out this week it says should Trump be
removed impeached and removed from
office it's upside-down now a 48 know 45
yes that is flipped from October if you
took a poll in West Virginia where would
it be today if we took a poll in West
Virginia would be 65 present no
impeachment and it would be a hundred
percent why don't you do the jobs that
you're sent to do which is to fund the
government support the military and move
forward on that really important issues
of the day and you think that this
process so far has already impeded big
legislative effort it has we haven't
gotten the National Defense
Authorization passed we haven't passed
USMC a the trade package with our
neighbors our Mexico and Canada which we
know would be very useful to my state
for the life of me I can't figure out
why that hasn't come forward except the
House of Representatives doesn't want to
give the president a win going into the
election we have an election in November
that's what elections are for last thing
you were just on a congressional
delegation overseas and you went to
Afghanistan speaking of the US military
we've been there on the ground for a
long time you're the thoughts about that
and the effort to get US troops back
home well I think we have 14,000 troops
there right now it was not lost on me
that the the areas that we're working on
in terms of counterterrorism whether
it's the Taliban or Isis or Al Qaeda are
exceedingly important that we help the
Afghan National forces and the Afghan
National Police and the government of
Afghanistan to secure more and more of
their territory because if we don't and
if we don't work in that train advise
and assist capacity that we've been
helping them with they're going to be
overtaken again by very violent
terrorist groups which then in dangers
our homeland it's about what's good for
our own security and and while it's been
long and hard and costly in a lot of
lives and treasure I think that in the
end keeping to help support them the
morale of the troops is great so proud
of them when we get to see them and for
the people who say hey
18 plus years we've done our duty there
I understand that and there are times
when I feel that way myself but I think
we can do a lot more with a lot less and
put a lot less lives in danger if we
follow the course that we've that we've
put forward we're planning to drawdown I
mean I think that's that's obvious and
the military leaders along with our NATO
partners feel that that's very much in
order as that Afghanistan government
we've got to strengthen that that is a
weak point right now because they've had
an election that's under under question
and and so I think as frustrating as it
is and and and difficult it is for the
American public we've got to look at our
homeland security and stabilizing that
region of the of the world is part of
our own homeland security senator
Shelley Moore capital of West Virginia
senator thanks for the time thank you
and Happy Thanksgiving